hello and first off congratulations
the film is is excellent i was
absolutely riveted
thanks barry thank you don i'm coming to
you first
having made the move from directorial
debut to second feature with
taylor was there anything about what he
did on those who
wish me dead that made you go like wow i
knew you were good but i didn't know you
were capable of that
to be honest with you it's it's the
stuff that i've i saw
you know had stayed with him you know i
i think the thing that's so exciting to
me about taylor is he's he's
you know he's an actor he's a writer
he's a director he's kind of he's kind
of
kind of done it all as a as a
storyteller and so he really
um he works with with with um real
empathy
and and understanding of of what each
person
in in the roles that they have uh you
know on a film set
he understands what everybody does and
and he treats everybody like a human
being
his set um it's a real community
everyone really wants to be there
everyone there's a real love there
there's a real belief in him there's a
real belief in that community and
and uh it's it's a very positive uh
place and and
i saw that on and that was uniform in
both films so
um that that was really uh i i was
really pleased by that
sometimes sometimes success can
you know make that stuff get muddy and
uh it wasn't it's all the same folks
that he's been working with
and uh there's a ton of love there and
that that that that that really made me
happy
i love hearing that especially about a
filmmaker i admire so much
right question for both of you now
because from my very limited perspective
it does feel like a great challenge to
convey
such depth and chemistry when you're two
characters in a fairly
large ensemble so what can
you do for each other as scene partners
in order to make that kind of chemistry
come through
well it's easy when
when you're working with someone who
you connect with before the cameras are
rolling who
is just like a kind genuine person
who you know puts you at ease and so you
don't have to work
for that part of it okay great and then
the cameras start rolling
and um working with an actor like john
who's present and who's spontaneous
and yeah so all of the you know kind of
like
sharp right corners that can be there
sometimes
just weren't um and so
yeah it was an ease and a pleasure
i bet the same way about you what's
something medina did for you as a scene
partner that you agree
that you really appreciated and maybe
you wish you saw more out there
oh man i mean every i mean really it's
it's it's what she just said it's it's a
it's a
you know it's um it's everything it's
not one thing it's everything it's the
way she conducts herself it's the way
how she is as a human being as an artist
you could tell how important this was
for her how much she she she believed in
this and how
she really want to say something with
this and and um
you know you know i i don't know you you
know you know kind of
at least i feel like you know kind of
immediately you you
know okay is this person is this person
here to really connect and and with
medina you're dealing with somebody
who's
ridiculously intelligent ridiculously
talented and really wants to
commit and explore and find something
with you you you you can't ask for a
better
you know partner for that and and i i
hate to say this because i i think a lot
of times you know
actors and perform they they try to like
overcomplicate they
it really does make that stuff kind of
easy
like you you you you just go you you ish
when you work with somebody like her you
really can just jump off
the the the ledge together and um you're
just gonna believe everything i believed
everything i was seeing
you know and so that that just that that
kind of does my job for me so i
enormously grateful i was enormously
grateful for her
thank you so much congratulations